- So, okay.
What are you teaching me today?
- Eggs with chickpeas and tomato sauce.
You can do it in five minutes.
- I mean, that's revelatory
because that's such a deterrent
because when they say
prep time 20 minutes,
cook time 60 minutes,
it's not realistic for
a lot of people's lives.
- So listen, we have the pan.
We have the oil, and you have garlic?
- I have garlic right here.
- Put the garlic on the pan,
and now talk to your garlic.
Tell, "Hey garlic, how are you?
How are you doing, baby?"
- Hey, baby, how's it going?
My kids' grandfather, Arie,
that's what he always says.
Hey, baby.
- The garlic is speaking back to you,
and the garlic is telling you,
"Oh, I'm so happy I'm
cooking with Drew and Jose.
It's amazing."
- I love garlic.
The more, the better.
- Okay, so in this moment,
we put the chickpeas now.
- Roger that.
- This is actually great
to buy a can of chickpeas,
which are delicious,
and usually they have very
good price on the supermarket.
- I was going to say,
I think they're a very
healthy thing for people,
and you have a vegetable
book, and for vegetarians
that are really satisfying
protein substitute.
I love them.
- So you take a look at the chickpeas.
They're so happy because they
love to be with the garlic.
People don't know this
but chickpeas and garlic,
they're very friendly, okay?
You have to lift up the temperature.
Put higher temperature, Drew.
- Oh, Jose, I'm so excited to tell you
that I just did that.
That means we're
telepathically linked now.
I'm in.
- So in this moment,
this is very important.
I will add a little bit
more of oil to your pan.
I love olive oil.
- By the way, check this olive oil out.
Oh, hang on, beauty shot.
There we go.
I love your olive oil.
Thank you so much for sending it to us.
- Let's say you have fresh tomatoes.
You can get a peeled fresh
tomato and cut it in cubes,
or you have canned tomatoes,
and also works very well,
or you have any pasta tomato
sauce that is already made.
Everything works.
Just make sure that you
do whatever you have
at home is what you use.
- I think that makes people
less stressed in the kitchen.
Thank you.
- Drew, recipes should
be like life itself.
When you don't have
some of the ingredients,
just move on, change the
recipe in your dishes
or in your life, and you'll
always be successful.
That's a very important lesson in cooking.
- And in life.
(audience applauding)
Jose, look, I'm sizzling, baby!
- So now, I have a can
of Spanish pimenton,
what we call paprika.
If you have it.
If you don't have
paprika, put chili flakes.
If you don't have, put cumin.
If you don't, put whatever
spice you have in your kitchen.
Make the recipe your own.
- Oh, paprika, I love you so.
- And now, I'm putting the tomato in.
Because this tomato is already cooked,
it's going to be easy.
I mean, I cannot believe, Drew,
that I am actually cooking with you.
I mean, when I told my
daughters, they were like,
"Come on, daddy.
Don't make fun of us."
Okay, I'm cooking.
I'm cooking with Drew Barrymore.
I'm cooking with her.
- Jose, how old are your daughters?
- I have three.
Carlota, she's 21, Ines,
she's 19, and Lucia, she's 16.
So listen, this is very important.
Now this tomato sauce, the
chickpea, everything is cooked,
and I am putting inside four or five eggs.
In this moment, you put
some salt on the eggs,
and ladies and gentleman,
to cover the pot,
and now you can open a glass of wine.
You're gonna open yourself a beer.
You can drink a sherry.
So why I'm doing this one pot, Drew,
because very often, many recipes,
they require three or four or five pots.
You can make everything with one pot.
No cleaning.
This is great.
- I love one pot.
I think it really helps people
feel like they can manage.
If they're not, I'm just
not that girl, who's like,
"So Betty, how was your day?"
I'm just stirring and casual.
I'm like.
(Drew screaming)
So one pot for me is a great
way to cook that keeps me calm.
- This pandemic I've been
cooking a lot with my daughters,
and we did some cooking on social media.
And quite frankly, we were
doing it because it was fun,
because we were spending so many hours,
and we began sharing it with people.
And was one of the best
moments of my life,
to be cooking with my three daughters.
Already, man, I remember
that first time I had them
in my arms and I was crying.
It was after they came up into the world,
and now 21 years later, I
realize through this pandemic
that they are these three grown up girls.
And to me, cooking with my daughters
has been the happiest moment of my life.
- Look at that, look at that, beauty shot!
And now I'm going to try it.
- Okay.
- Yup, oh yeah.
Oh God, that's good.
- The great thing about this dish is that
you can make it your own in so many ways.
You can cook it every time,
and every time be a different recipe.
You can put some mozzarella.
You can put some manchego cheese.
- Ooh, topping it with
cheese would kick it up
a whole other level, you're right.
- And don't be afraid
of trying new things.
Always, you take risk.
They will always pay off.
(audience cheering)
- Jose, you make the world a better place
and you help us be better
people with your wisdom.
(upbeat music)